et si la situation est plutôt calme les
gens vivent leur vie vous le voyez ils
vont travailler ils sont dans les rues
aux faux dire aussi qu'il fait c'est
bosser l'été dont on voit plutôt un
certain calme du côté de ses habitants
on a pu parler avec un habitant de kiev
qui nous a d'ailleurs expliqué bien que
finalement ils s'étaient habitués
notamment aux alertes régulières en cas
de bombardement il ya finalement que les
habitants qui sont récemment revenus à
kiev et bien qu'ils ont peur de ces
alertes mais ça concerne donc uniquement
les habitants et bien qu'ils avaient fui
kiev il ya encore quelques semaines et
qui ont décidé de rentrer assez
rapidement le soir on a pu constater
quand même un peu les rues de kiev ce
vide assez rapidement puisqu'il ya
toujours un couvre feu qui est en
vigueur il débute à 23 heures on a pu
aussi constater qu'il y à toujours
évidemment bien sûr plusieurs check pas
une teinte dans la ville et notamment à
l'entrée de la ville il y a aussi ses
vous savez ces gros blocs de béton et
bien qu'ils ont été à certains endroits
déplacer sur le côté mais seulement
déplacé pas enlevé bien sûr au cas où et
puis sachez également et bien que les
enfants en tout cas ceux qui le peuvent
sont al depuis le début de mois de juin
en vacances jusqu'ici les suivis tous
leurs cours via zoomer on a appris et
bien que évidemment pour l'instant ils
ne savent pas du tout s'ils pourront
reprendre leur cours début septembre